Speaker 1: Let's go to Roy from
South Jersey next. Welcome, Roy.
Speaker 2: Hi, David. Hi. So I was wondering,
you know, Biden said that he would get the
Equality Act passed within his first hundred
days. That didn't happen. Chuck Schumer said
he'd bring it to the floor in june pride
month last year. That didn't happen. So
do you think it's ever going to happen?
Speaker 1: No, probably not. I mean, if
I'm totally honest with you, I just I just don't
see it happening anytime soon, particularly now
with what's going on with the shootings. Ukraine
still going on, midterms coming up. I think
now Senate's on some kind of break or was on a
break. I don't see it. I don't see it happening.
Speaker 2: That's unfortunate.
Now, I had another question.
My both my parents think that the election was
stolen, but for various reasons. Okay, Mom, as
you say, her mind is mayonnaise and she thinks the
Cuban on and everything Trump wanted to say, but.
Speaker 1: She thinks Trump won every state.
Speaker 2: Yes, that's even California.
That's correct. Wow. Yeah. Now my dad thinks, oh,
well, you know, in Pennsylvania, they changed the
rules for drop boxes and, you know, stuff like
that. So that's why it's stolen. Right. Which
is more dangerous, do you think? Uh hmm.
Speaker 1: Well, I don't know that the
ideas themselves are necessarily more or less
dangerous. It's sort of what people do with them.
So I don't know that I'm like super crystal
clear on it. Do you knowing the two of them,
do you have a sense of which is more dangerous?
Speaker 2: I mean, you know, my dad's arguments
make more sense to people, even
though they don't make sense.
Obviously, the legislatures can
change the rules to the elections.
That's simple. But yeah, you know, I mean,
on paper, yes. My mom's like more more crazy.
But my dad seemed to convince more people. So
that's, you know, where I'm struggling with.
Speaker 1: That's a common that's a common thing
we've talked about before, which is what's worse,
a really crazy politician who can't get anything
done, but their ideas are more dangerous
versus a marginally less crazy politician
who is is less dangerous in their ideas,
but might actually be able to make some of
their ideas a reality. It's it's sort of a
similar thing. And I think it's you got to take
it on a case by case basis. I don't think the
presence of large swaths of Americans believing
either of the things your parents believe is
particularly good, let's put it that way.
Speaker 2: That's fair. Yeah. Now. Now,
one last thing. Did you see the the trailer
for the Winnie the Pooh horror movie?
Speaker 1: No, it's not even a thing.
I've never even heard that there was
a Winnie the Pooh horror movie.
Speaker 2: It came out recently
that this is happening. Disney lost the
rights to it because some intern forgot to
renew the lease or whatever, and some guy
picked it up and he's making a horror movie,
and it looks terrible, but I'm going to see it.
Speaker 1: Okay. Wow. Very good. Hey, listen,
one other thing about your parents are
do either of them have delusional beliefs
about anything other than the election,
or is it compartmentalized only to the election?
Speaker 2: Oh. I mean, my dad, you know,
he he he's all right, you know, he he
jokes around a bit, but my mom. Yeah,
she's she's a lunatic on on many fronts.
Speaker 1: Oh, like what, what other,
what else does she believe that she'll mention.
Speaker 2: Well, you know, she thinks that,
you know, you can just cure a scratch with just,
you know, healing and thinking and instead of,
you know, getting medical advice or whatever.
She thinks that she cured cancer by,
you know, wishing it away. So, you
know, she's I'm worried because,
you know, she smokes a lot. And I think she's
going to get lung cancer and then she's not
going to get treatment because she thinks she
can just do this and then she's going to die.
Speaker 1: Wait. Now, Roy, she. I'm
guessing you mean she thinks she cured
someone else's cancer with prayer?
Speaker 2: No, her own. I don't. I
don't think she did have cancer at all. So.
Speaker 1: Wait, wait, hold that. Wait, let me. So
you're not even sure your mom had cancer, but
she believes she had it and cured it with prayer?
Speaker 2: That's correct.
Speaker 1: But she was
never diagnosed with cancer.
Speaker 2: That is correct.
Speaker 1: Wow. And so why did
she believe she had cancer?
Speaker 2: She had like a
lump on her arm or something.
Speaker 1: And then she prayed and it went away.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Do you think it might have
just been like a cyst or something?
Speaker 2: It's definitely possible. Wow.
Speaker 1: Wow. I feel really bad for you,
Roy. That sounds like a really tough
situation. How old the guy are you?
Speaker 2: I am 23. 24. And the week.
Speaker 1: Okay. And are you, like,
out of the home or do you live with
these parents you're describing?
Speaker 2: I live with my dad. My mom's separated.
Speaker 1: Got it. Got it. Okay. Wow. Well,
listen, Roy, you've got
you've got your hands full.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Yeah. Well,
I appreciate you sharing your story.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. There's Roy. Wow. That is
that is full on. That is weaponized when we talk
about weaponized beliefs. That's really what
we're talking about. That is that is something